another election season is upon us and
that can mean only one thing i'm running
for governor and i want to tell you why
the return of the most radical
skateboard dude in the known universe
beto francis now after a failed run at
the senate and the presidency beto is
now setting his sights on becoming the
next governor of texas hell yes we're
going to take your ar-15 your ak-47 and
what better way to gin up enthusiasm
than to head to
livingston
now here's where i should say i have
nothing against livingston
it's a nice town filled with friendly
and welcoming people
i'm sorry
i'm not racist
well
i'll take that back
but i couldn't help wonder
why beto chose to hold one of his town
halls here especially since donald trump
won the county by 54
points in 2020.
now i would have loved to investigate
this matter myself but considering that
these organizations now have my poster
up on a wall in my stead i decided to
send a team
of my finest to see what beta and the
town we're all about
[Music]
now the first thing they noted about the
whole charade was the venue it was not
exactly uh huge i mean if i were to give
a generous estimate a very generous
estimate i'd place it at maybe about 110
people now what the event lacked in
attendance however it more than made up
for with the kind of enthusiasm
which can only be found in the most
youthful among us
so are you excited about vado
there was also a lot of electric energy
from other people
[Music]
one lovely local summed it up uh quite
succinctly uh-uh no veto ain't right of
course it's rude to show up to a party
empty-handed so my fine reporters
decided to hand out some betto themed
t-shirts to show support t-shirts
just go into the building and give them
at the merchandise that's great thank
you yeah
thank you appreciate it
beto staffers weren't so keen on the
shirts being free uh while they were
trying to turn a profit with theirs
[Music]
so you're trying to do a little bit of
capitalism up in here down was
capitalism
like generally peter like they're beta
males you know like they're not good but
we think that's stupid so we're trying
to like subvert it turn it on it's head
be like nah beto is cool yeah and so
we're beto males
okay like just kind of turn i don't know
she got very mad yeah yeah
i don't what did she say to you she was
like
what'd she say that it was it's not a
bed
yeah it's not a better shirt or
something like that it's not it's not
official but the team wasn't just there
to observe uh we wanted them to get to
the meat
of vado's policies really get to know
the man luckily for them beto couldn't
resist the pheromonal allure of our
bedos
[Music]
so
it sounds like you have such a great
plan for schools and and the trajectory
there
but i have a question so that all that
good work doesn't go undone
um
you know obviously i want to be as
inclusive as possible but even last
night when we were at dinner somebody
offered us drugs
and so
i'd like to just hear how do you how do
you thread that needle of inclusivity
being welcoming
while also
stopping some fentanyl i don't know i'd
like to hear if you have thoughts on
that
i really appreciate the question
there's probably nothing more important
than the safety and security of our
communities of our families especially
our kids and our grandkids we see under
abbott's failed leadership violent crime
going up drug trafficking
going up when we're focused on pulling
stunts i can't believe you're a sick son
of a [ __ ] that would come to a deal
like this to make a political issue and
scoring political points we take our eye
off the ball and the real problem
where it is i'll give you some examples
remember when he signed the abortion ban
where is this going governor you
understand there's no exception for
incest
how do we get here and like a deer
caught in the headlights he said well
we're going to eliminate bridges
when i'm governor we're going to focus
on that and public safety is going to
improve in the state of texas thanks for
asking the question appreciate it
oh that was a lot of nothing quite a bit
of talking
a lot of nothing let's give it one more
shot hello hello man how you doing very
good how are you doing good i'm reuben
perez
um
we're both catholic right yes okay i'm
having an issue real fast my family i
think you're great i want them to vote
for you but they're they have the
sticking point with the pro-choice thing
you know we're both pro-choice they're
not what do you think i can tell them to
maybe help persuade them to vote for you
i don't know anyone who is pro-choice or
pro-life who
is happy with what we're doing in texas
right now ah
here we go again
[Music]
maybe if he can bore his audience to
actual death he can guarantee their vote
the next election
beto is playing 8d chess
speaking of death beto it should be
noted that we aren't your biggest fans
no surprise but we do want you to be
safe so maybe invest in a better
security team that doesn't allow random
passers-by and camera people to walk up
directly behind you and follow you
backstage
[Music]
especially if the person in question is
a grown man with pigtails and a t-shirt
that simply reads autism
all right that's enough what are the
good towns people of livingston texas
think of all this do you think the
personality of the candidate matters
pretty dramatically definitely more than
any issue
in my book if you can answer the
questions that are asked of you and if
you don't know the answer
at least say you know i'm not sure
he's done that that button
uh
obama i had three
biden signed big ones okay stole off my
property yeah and i was more than
willing to leave wait for him to show
back
and do what
[Music]
so are you excited about vado oh yeah
yeah
what do you think you can do for the
state that happened
well like we were just talking about
her her son who is a lot younger
uh
was talking about well
where's his big money coming from well
they all get big money right and
i'm more concerned about where the heart
of the person is getting that money
is to begin with
that sign's [ __ ] amazing
did you get this side what's more
important to you the
policy or the personality
i would say policy
i think
like freedom of speech
pro guns pro-life
we've been asking the same question to
everybody we've interviewed so i'm very
curious what your opinion is when it
comes to a political candidate which is
more important the personality or the
policies of that candidate
that's a good question i think they're
both equally important
uh you look at trump you know look what
he did in four years and they screwed
with him the entire time
because of his personality and because
of his
policies
you know if they'd left him alone we
would have been a lot better off better
off further along than we are right now
so i'd have to say both honestly hold on
so one group cares about policies while
the other cares about personality and
feelings i am jack's complete lack of
surprise i had a question though so like
i know somebody
that is here maybe not
quite procedure that's very difficult mr
abbott has made it very difficult to do
that
how what can
happen
like
i don't
i don't ask the question i don't want to
use the words
it's a
you would be in very big trouble under
mr abbott if you want to seek out that
procedure yeah
um listen i'd be happy to take a picture
with you um and while beto francis was
understandably hesitant to answer my
team's questions credit where it's due
he was still gracious enough to take the
time for a picture
with his new beto male bros
that's right
look at this picture
this happened so remember when you think
of beto for governor
just think of this
exact picture
i'm sorry
i'm not racist
well
i'll take that back
yes i am racist
i like nascar more than i do
indianapolis cars
that's funny